[Musica]
voi conoscete qualcuno che Prova a
cambiare il mondo qualcuno che non sia
un supereroi ragazzi quelli non valgono
Ok Non vedo mani alzate Allora vado
avanti e vi racconto una storia che non
è solo la mia un anno e mezzo fa più o
meno conosciuto i volontari di Shepherd
dei ragazzi che offrono il loro tempo
per fare i guardiani del mare i pirati
buoni del mare e quando ho deciso di
scrivere il documentario su di loro Il
primo frame quello che si vede
all'inizio del film dice questo non
bisognerebbe mai dubitare che un piccolo
gruppo di persone possono cambiare il
mondo Quando li ho incontrati ho pensato
bisogna fare qualcosa e allora ho fatto
quello che che so fare quello che faccio
tutti i giorni con la mia piccola casa
di produzione e cioè raccontare la loro
storia che non è la storia dell'ung
giuro che non so per attaccarvi un
pippone sulla NG ma è la storia di come
Queste persone pensano di provare a
cambiare il mondo e la loro storia di
come loro investono il loro tempo
e così quando ho deciso di iniziare ho
pensato che per fare questo documentario
servivano un sacco di soldi e io non
avevo chi poteva pagare per me e anche
un sacco di persone e il fatto che tutti
quelli che ci hanno lavorato sono saliti
letteralmente a bordo di questo progetto
sapendo Qual è la situazione per me ha
un valore inestimabile e non è un caso
che alcuni di loro stasera siano qui vi
parlo di soldi è in elegante no parlare
di soldi perché la vita
amici miei non è solo filosofia è anche
molto pratica la vita e per fare un film
ci vogliono veramente un sacco di
persone in ogni caso io credevo che
fosse giusto raccontare la storia di
queste persone e ho iniziato per esempio
a scrivere parlando di Serena una
ragazza di di vent'anni una anarchica
gentile una che fa le rivoluzioni
silenziose ovviamente vegana come tutti
i volontari di Sissa Perché in genere fa
questa cosa subdola di invitare a cena
ai propri amici i suoi coetanei Lei
cucina molto bene e alla fine della cena
li guarda Soprattutto negli occhi per
qualche secondo gli dice era buono vero
Non hai mangiato neanche un animale
oppure di Fabio e ottacaccina abbiamo
parlato anche di loro mentre ho pensato
anche loro mentre scrivevo il mio
progetto che hanno i loro Food Truck
vegano girano nel nord Italia e sono una
coppia e le loro vacanze le passano da
diversi anni a bordo delle navi di
Seychelles e io che ci sono state per
diversi mesi vi posso assicurare che è
tutto tranne che una vacanza oppure nel
migliore dei casi Fabio ottacaccin le
loro vacanze scelgono di passarle in
base al momento dell'anno Purtroppo a
fare gli appostamenti per esempio alle
isole faro e per evitare le mattanze
questo documentario è stata anche la
storia di chi ci ha lavorato come come
Matteo meldo il film era più forte che
conosco che è capace di prendere tre
aliscafi due elicotteri quattro gommoni
solo per salvare l'hard disk con le
interviste Che altrimenti sarebbero
andate perse perché erano
importantissime ecco per dire quanto ci
credono quanto che sei persone ci
credono
E allora A proposito di crederci faccio
un salto all'indietro che comincia a
diventare nostalgica con l'età
e vado a 10 anni fa il 30 settembre di
10 anni fa era una ragazzina Avevo 27
anni ed ero in Afghanistan e anche
quella volta ho pensato che bisogna fare
qualcosa non sapevo niente degli stand
del Turkmenistan tirjikistan Afghanistan
Kazakistan Pakistan non sapevo niente
quello che sapevo è che secondo me era
ingiusto quello che stava succedendo nel
mondo c'era una guerra ingiusta e
trovavo ingiusto pensare di aver chiuso
delle persone dentro i loro stessi
confini avergli tirato delle bombe in
testa ha ritirato loro il Passaporti e
averli Resi profughi nel loro stesso
paese e poi avergli detto Vabbè adesso
gestitevela un po' voi qui così noi
Intanto stiamo qua
peraltro queste persone sono che ho
conosciuto in Afghanistan sono persone
gente normale gente che ascolta la
musica usavano già lo Smartphone per
comunicare e andavano al lavoro al
parrucchiere volevano fare sport durante
il tempo libero penso per esempio a
parwin una ragazza di 28 anni di Kabul
eravamo sei meglio a quel tempo che
avrebbe dato letteralmente un braccio
per studiare e quando delle volte penso
che io non mi sono anche presa il lusso
di non finire gli esami per la mia
laurea Ecco mi gira un po' la testa tra
l'altro parumi le braccia non le è
neanche più perché l'ha persa Due anni
fa sopra una mina in estate esplodono
più spesso così come informazione di
servizio
è servita la mia presenza in Afghanistan
come reporter non credo Non lo so non so
se ho cambiato un pezzo di mondo Quello
che so è che sono sicura che fosse
giusto esserci perché lì ho conosciuto
Pangea Emergency un sacco di NG i
militari della mia scorta Alcuni di loro
non ci sono più
ho conosciuto i turkmeni gli afghani e
gli indiani e sono sicura Oggi sono
sicura che la guerra mi fa paura
e lo vedo succedere di nuovo è così
vicina a noi lo vedo sedere nuovo e
anche quella volta io ho provato a
raccontare delle pagine dei quotidiani
ora non lo faccio più ma ci ho creduto e
pensava che bisognasse fare qualcosa io
adesso non vi sto dicendo di prendere la
giacca che fa freddo in Ucraina e
guidare fino ai confini della Russia non
vi sto dicendo questo non lasciate il
teatro Bonci adesso che poi mi sento
sola qui sul palco dico che non tutti
sentono il bisogno di fare qualcosa però
se senti il bisogno di fare qualcosa
allora fallo perché è adesso il momento
giusto è sempre il momento giusto anche
perché un'opera vive per sempre e noi no
e quelle cose che ho scritto rimarranno
per sempre quelle persone che ho
guardato negli occhi in mezzo alla
polvere in mezzo ai cattivi odori la
morte è un cattivo odore Ecco quegli
sguardi rimarranno
rimarranno per sempre Ormai siamo un po'
abituati no delegare il cambiamento
alle no profit pensiamo che siano le no
profit che devono occuparsi di cambiare
il mondo
l'educazione dei nostri figli alla
scuola la grondaia che perde del nostro
condominio all'amministratore di
condominio e allora quando penso a tutte
queste cose penso uno dei Pescatori che
ho conosciuto cercando di realizzare
questo documentario penso a Nicola un
pescatore virtuoso è uno di quelli
legali uno ritenuto davvero una fan
prodige nel suo settore che un giorno
allora del tramonto mi ha detto a dì ma
io faccio il pescatore ci dovrà pur
pensare il buon governo a darmi le reti
biodegradabili io cosa posso fare io
faccio il pescatore
e no Nicola no no Tu puoi fare la tua
parte perché magari le reti
biodegradabili le puoi comprare già tu e
costano uguale a quelle di plastica così
le usi e ci fai anche il favore di non
lasciare la plastica nel mare
dico che ognuno dovrebbe fare la propria
parte io non so cosa voglio fare da
grande di sicuro non Il Pescatore So che
però non sono disposta a delle gare Non
so voi però io ultimamente in questi
ultimi anni sono un po' confusa dagli
youtuber dai social media dal metaverso
adesso che che mi vogliono vendere
violentemente quest'idea per cui puoi
stare in vacanza Fuerteventura che tra
l'altro un'isola che io amo moltissimo
Ci vado ogni volta che posso scappo lì
Quando posso che tu puoi vivere in
vacanza senza non fare niente guadagnare
un sacco di soldi cercano un po' di
venderci queste idee qua non so se
l'avete notato
Ecco io non sono d'accordo secondo me
nella vita ti devi fare il culo e tra
l'altro può succedere che mentre ti fai
il culo fallisci anche Però questo non
importa perché l'importante è che tu ti
faccia il culo per qualcosa in cui credi
perché quella cosa Poi vive per sempre
un'opera ti mette in condizione di
iniziare da capo ogni volta
ho paura di cosa farò domani Sì a volte
sì a volte ho paura di non riuscire a
pagare gli stipendi di tutti i miei
collaboratori però sono forte quando
queste paure delle parole che per
esempio mi ha detto Ota sempre non dei
volontari disse per due Una volta dalla
poppa della sigor Eravamo lì A
raccontarcela tra noi due e lei mi ha
detto vedi Ma io sono sempre un
attivista non è che quando scendo da
questa nave di 40 metri dove siamo su da
due mesi mi tolgo questa felpa nera col
logo dei Pirati e non sono più un
attivista Io sono un attivista tutti i
giorni perché lei ci crede e tra l'altro
lei può anche fallire non avete idea di
che vita frustrante fanno i volontari
falliscono ogni giorno
Ecco quindi dieci anni fa quello che mi
ha fatto pensare che bisognasse fare
qualcosa è stato l'Afghanistan poi nella
mia personale carriera è stato il bel
momento di raccontare lo sport
attraverso
l'opera le gesta Se volete
incredibili di persone fuori dal comune
come come Valentino Rossi Come Francesco
Bagnaia magari qualcuno di voi È diffuso
di moto ha appena vinto il motomondiale
e poi ho sentito il bisogno di tornare a
scrivere di tornare al mare con i
guardiani del mare quel documentario di
cui sopra di quale vi dicevo e sapete
come è finita per questo progetto che è
nato così senza soldi senza speranze
Insomma senza c'erano molti senza
ecco per quel documentario è finita che
è stato visto in occasione della mostra
internazionale del cinema di Venezia
che ha sempre una cosa abbastanza
da dire E siete d'accordo anche voi
e adesso sono una piattaforma che vedono
un sacco di persone ma la cosa più
importante è che siamo riusciti anche a
donare dei soldi a chi c'è per facendo
questo documentario io questa sera vi ho
raccontato la storia di queste persone
di questi volontari e un po' anche la
mia perché io percepisco un po' parlando
con i miei amici con le persone che
conosco che ci sia un po' questa scusa
nell'aria che serve sempre qualcosa che
non abbiamo per cambiare le cose per
cambiare il mondo e non è vero È una
scusa non cascateci
Ecco io non so che cosa farò da grande e
tra l'altro cominciano ad avere 37 anni
potrebbe essere un problema a un certo
punto però so che il mio lavoro è
raccontare storie raccontare le persone
so che ci sono alcune opere che ancora
in mente di fare e ho ancora voglia di
ricominciare da capo mille volte
prima di salutarvi vi dirò delle cose
molto ovvie cose che sappiamo già
Tra le cose che sappiamo già per esempio
c'è che il mare sta morendo Tra l'altro
il mare ha questa peculiarità fastidiosa
di essere enorme di produrre ossigeno
per cui se il mare muore muoriamo Anche
noi vi dico un'altra cosa ovvia c'è la
guerra ed è molto vicina Dove siamo
adesso proprio molto vicino a dove ci
troviamo precisamente ci sono 10 guerre
nel mondo in questo momento Quindi
mentre vi sto parlando probabilmente c'è
qualcuno che sta perdendo tutto nella
sua vita
e vi dico anche un'ultima cosa che
comunque il mondo Esiste ancora il mondo
lo teniamo in piedi noi non loro Noi qui
dentro stasera dentro il teatro Noi
stiamo tenendo in piedi un pezzo di
mondo e non siamo neanche dei supereroi
perché si può sempre fare qualcosa Io mi
fermo qui Grazie
[Applauso]